let's begin
I'm Greg I'm John hi stranger I'm amber
amber Platzer from the amber placer
channel where she's constantly
plastering herself hi stranger it's the
video today how many how many name puns
do you get in a week ah every time
someone learns I'm acting like so do you
get plastered and I remember like being
in kindergarten and being like I don't
know what that is when you were in see
where they go like run faster plaster
yeah yeah I'm sorry fine I like my last
name I'm okay with a record yeah
all right guys nothing digging around
let's watch this serious drama
oh god this weird viral video hi
stranger
it's been a while
[Music]
I've missed you it's okay you can look
at my butt really
imagine it's an illusion Wow check out
the sunset so nice to stop and take all
this in and then they enjoy being alive
[Music]
remember all machines
[Music]
they're sitting
[Music]
little details are great
[Music]
if you like your camera's oxidated right
now it's just your picture I've been
thinking about it a lot lately I see you
trying to do so many things in words
worrying about a decision you made
worried that you said the wrong thing to
someone so hard on myself it's wonderful
be worthy being loved
you really are we just have to let
yourself believe it
well baby probably have to go I'm glad I
got to see you
okay that was amazing it's pretty great
pretty you know um what are my chances
that people will watch this later not
sober I kind of just want to keep
watching it all day like I just kind of
want to have this on a loop I love it
when things get like oddly soothing yeah
like they're weird and surreal but also
kind I feel like the video like starting
off with like how you can look at my
butt and all that saying like slow down
and appreciate life like no matter
what's weird around you just accept it
all and bring it all in just enjoy it
felt really good bless you hey I don't
see this by the end yeah yeah once the
initial like strangeness wears off you
know yeah because it kind of lures you
into this sort of like yeah yeah I don't
you a lot of stuff yeah we work hard
you're right
to me this is drawing me it's videos
like this of why YouTube so famous know
this and I'm like it's been a losses I
just saw a random weird video on YouTube
in latakia this is classic YouTube
territory right here sort of like
surreal so yeah this reminds me that
early YouTube video that I think was
like a song and someone just made a
video out of it this guy tripping on
acid and then he made like a claymation
to it is really common it's like a gecko
or whatever yeah yeah cuz we can't get
the floor he's like share whatever the
[ __ ] hook that share [ __ ] it don't
look in the shaft yeah I got the funny
xanaxs yeah I got a classic internet
yeah just like random stuff that you
would stumble across before the age of
influencers before the age of Adz on
YouTube you would Rumble across like
weird stuff like this on the internet I
miss it so much so
good Thank You Kirsten Lapua I'm sure a
woman did you could do this
yes that's what this is prettier woman I
am NOT an animator but I could be you
could write it in court
Kirsten has proved that to me yeah yeah
definitely the guy has a nice voice
again is very soon probably satisfied as
many people dude if you put on some like
big ass headphones there's probably like
you know a little bit of an ASMR
experience you know that boy the has
made mark can you know these KarenT if
he doesn't you need to man this is how
many pieces of a video have this is
going to be a video where people are
going to start trying to decipher the
meaning and philosophical context when
really the filmmaker was probably like
this is just funny weird I don't think
it's so hard to animate like it takes a
lot of time to do claymation animation
that they've just like let's just write
something just as a task so they like
let's lean into this yeah this almost
feels like yeah and I feel like a piece
that came together very stream of
consciousness light or or just she had
such a specific vision and he does yeah
yeah genius like I would love to know
how this came together and which parts
came first and because it's so specific
that needs to like live on like a very
obscure playlist with like only other
videos that are this weird every every
party playlist I ever design nouns can
have something I can see John being that
person one day just hanging out on a
satin sheet reading my assistants draw
your people and like I walk in Courage
and he feels like a red flower yeah like
you like this flower is really hard
making things is it's really hard making
things I feel like John is back though
you should look at my dick okay okay
okay
you have an almost day
maybe we have to do is do a real life
version evisceration I'll shoot you
doing that my not you oh but I'll be my
ass on YouTube already alright only
about time to see yours
alright I gotta go to the gym more than
I got it no can't skip link I did it
even heavier I'm gonna let it have like
a most kind of like I was fatter and I
really have big but just in a bad shape
people just want to see nudity and you
got to give the people get everybody
everybody's body type is a type for
somebody I want to be proud of mine of
my bum and so I put it on the internet
and and you know like at this you know I
need orbit will see G when when I put it
on the unit Thank You amber yeah Kiana
then you just committed and we heard it
oh and I think we should do a real life
I can you cook you just have a shot of
someone's ass on YouTube where we'll be
acting asses on YouTube yeah where will
we find enough silk to come entire rooms
the expanse of a room always make the
shot right lens right line right lens
and then we're gonna have to pan to like
a sunset yeah yeah if it's just you to
work for work it'll be some cut
practical effect
yeah with serene history okay we're
gonna do it a new Kickstarter for this
oh yeah yeah I wonder if anyone has
actually reenacted this yet tree farm
that's how we're the real rejects save
spectres from a Seth Rogen did the Kanye
and cover of yeah that's what this means
it means to be a very honest cover
that's what I want to do like a very
heartfelt like nice no I'm all about
this I do it I'm going to show you my
phone your again a production meeting if
I do it I'm going to shave my entire
body head to toe oh yeah I'm going to be
well he is here loyalties exactly he's
hairless someone in your head
everything everything hair even the
frame is all the way around my stomach
if I'm gonna be this character I can't
shave I got it I gotta shave it off he's
kind of like Voldemort's horny other cuz
younger cousin corny like well-balanced
all the board's because until I knew in
the library I was like
yeah I try to talk to him you know he's
doing so many things all the time
all right well subscribe to the real
rejects reasons too scary I put on
Instagram social media manager of blah
MIDI Blum the house and the real rejects
she's on afterbuzz TV but more
importantly she has her own channel
called Amber placer yeah go there watch
her videos immediately or you right now
die a horrible death by me strangling
you I'll strain 88 out of you is such a
kind endorsement of course I will
strangle and I'm going to enjoy it no
reminds me of those old chain letters or
it's like you don't share this with 10
people like I'm gonna come to your house
yeah when there were ones arrived
apparently will die yeah I'm not kidding
this side like I saw you had the right
foot this time it's real perfect you
real and then you said then I share it
real I've had a lot of people die in my
life because I cannot share I hear chef
your shared and you're gonna fear
subscribe to my channel now oh man
that's it that's a way to build a
fanbase well all the comments much
others that fear Bobbie